simplifica 3x al cuadrado menos 8 x 7
más 2 x al cubo menos x al cuadrado más
8 x menos 3 muy bien esto de simplificar
es sumar y restar términos para que esto
sea una expresión un poco más sencilla
sin embargo solo podemos sumar o restar
términos si son similares déjame hacer
un pequeño recordatorio de que quería
decir esto por ejemplo si teníamos y si
tenemos una x cuadrada y lo queremos
sumar con otro x cuadrada si podemos
hacerlo porque tienen el mismo exponente
y entonces tendríamos 2 x al cuadrado de
manera similar si queremos sumar no sé
digamos un 3 x al cubo con un 4 x al
cubo 4 x al cubo entonces también
podemos sumarlos porque tienen el mismo
exponente y tendríamos 7 x al cubo algo
que no podemos hacer es simplificar x al
cuadrado más x al cubo porque ahora
tienen exponentes distintos entonces
esta expresión de aquí le voy a poner
que no se puede simplificar no se puede
puede
calificar
sin aplicar ok
después de este recordatorio ahora si
vamos al problema entonces queremos
sumar términos similares los que tengan
el mismo exponente vamos a empezar con
el exponente más grande que me parece
que es 3 si es 3 y al parecer nada más
hay un sumando que tiene x al cubo y
existiría acá el 2 x al cubo entonces
ese lo voy a poner aquí abajo 2 x al
cubo vamos a ver que otros hay vamos a
cuadrado aquí tenemos un trekkies 3x
cuadrada y aquí tenemos un menos equis
cuadrada entonces déjame juntar este 3x
cuadrada y este menos x cuadrada todavía
no los vamos a sumar nada más dejan
escribirlos aquí 3 x al cuadrado menos x
al cuadrado
ok vámonos con los que tienen x a la 1
los términos lineales entonces voy a
marcar con este color verde que serían
menos 8 x y 8 x entonces le pongo menos
8 x
8x y finalmente los términos constantes
que no tienen equis o bien que podemos
pensar que están multiplicados por equis
a la cero entonces sería más 7 menos 3
muy bien entonces hasta ahorita lo único
que he hecho es aprovechar la propiedad
conmutativa de la suma y la resta para
reacomodar los términos y juntar los
términos similares ahora sí vamos a
simplificar vamos a realizar las
operaciones déjame tomar el morado
entonces este 2x al cubo se queda como 2
x al cubo luego aquí tenemos 3x cuadrada
y le estamos quitando una x al cuadrado
y a 3 le quitamos 1 nos queda nada más 2
x al cuadrado
2x cuadradas luego aquí tenemos 8 x
menos 8 x xi o bueno menos 8 x 8 x es lo
mismo porque podemos intercambiarlos
pero estamos cancelando pues todos los
2x es verdad entonces aquí nos quedarían
0 x podría ponerle más 0 x pero eso
sería redundante entonces simplemente no
voy a escribir nada y finalmente hay que
sumar 7 y restar 3 7 menos 3 es igual a
entonces voy a ponerle más +4 muy bien
con esto terminamos y logramos
simplificar la expresión y nos quedó 2x
al cubo más 2 x al cuadrado más 4